bienvenue à besançon émission spéciale
ce matin c'est dans cette cité des arts
et de la culture juste derrière nous que
france 3 a réuni quelques-uns des
principaux candidats aux élections
régionales
oui nous désignerons dans deux mois
maintenant la première assemblée
régionale bourgogne franche comté
quel président pour quoi faire on en
débat tout de suite dans la voix est
libre on y va c'est parti bonjour à tous
émission spéciale donc dans la voix est
libre ce samedi
nous sommes à la cité des arts et de la
culture de besançon pour le premier
débat des élections régionales de
décembre prochain eric on a réuni sur ce
plateau quelques uns des principaux
candidats
oui et ce d'abord marie-guite dufay
bonjour vous êtes la présidente
socialiste sortante du conseil régional
de franche-comté tête de liste pour le
parti socialiste
françois sauvadet bonjour député
président du conseil départemental de la
côte d'or et vous êtes donc la tête de
liste pour lui dit et les républicains
sophie montel
bonjour vous êtes députée européenne
conseillère régionale sortante de
franche comté est tête de liste pour le
front national
cécile prud'hommes bonjour vous êtes
tête de liste pour europe ecologie les
verts
nathalie vermorel présidente du groupe
communiste au conseil régional de
bourgogne chef de file du parti
communiste pour ces élections
et puis christophe grudler bons joueurs
conseiller départemental du territoire
de belfort est tête de liste pour le
modem vous nous en direz plus tout à
l'heure et puis je vous précise qu'il y
a quatre autres listes annoncé celles
qui sont menées par maxime thibeault
pour debout la france charles henri
gallois pour l'union populaire
républicaine claire rocher pour lutte
ouvrière et julien gonzalez pour
l'alliance écologiste indépendante
alors mesdames messieurs au cours de
cette émission nous allons débattre bien
sûr de vos projets pour la bourgogne
franche comté notamment en matière
économique ce sera la principale
compétence des conseils régionaux mais
d'abord on aimerait connaître votre
ligne politique à tous
vos partenaires éventuels pour former
une majorité qui est prêt à travailler
avec qui on va commencer avec vous
marie-guite dufay vous êtes donc
présidente sortante du conseil régional
de franche comté vous avez été la
première à présenter vos candidats
essentiellement des candidats
socialistes
et pourtant en bourgogne comme en
franche comté les exécutifs sortants
était composée de socialistes mais aussi
d'écologistes dans les deux régions de
chevènementiste ici en franche comté de
communistes en bourgogne
pourquoi avoir choisi de ne pas vous
présenter dès le premier tour avec ses
partenaires sortant contrairement à ce
que vous venez de dire il n'y a pas que
des socialistes sur les listes que je
présente puisque au contraire j
essentiellement puisqu'au contraire et
j'en suis fier g j'ai eu comme objectif
le maximum d'ouverture dans un contexte
où effectivement je regrette et j'ai eu
l'occasion de le dire à plusieurs
reprises le fait qu'il ne soit pas
possible de faire alliance ni avec
europe ecologie les verts ni avec le
parti communiste qui ont décidé pour le
premier tour et c'est une position
nationale effectivement de se présenter
de leur côté ce n'est notre
vivre-ensemble sur l'ensemble de l'été
liste j'ai un tiers de non socialistes
et j'en suis extrêmement fier d'autant
et je suis fier également d'avoir pu
constituer l'ensemble de ses listes avec
116 candidat dès le mois de septembre
dernier la fin du mois de septembre ce
qui me permet de démarrer aujourd'hui ce
que j'avais voulu c'est à dire une
campagne participative avec nos
militants nos sympathisants pour à
l'occasion de rencontres sur tout le
territoire
affiné nos éléments de programme police
n'ont pas plu à tout le monde notamment
à 3 vice présidente sortante de françois
patriat safia otokoré florence ombret
fadila khattabi qui ont regretté de ne
pas être au départ sur vos listes
comment vous justifier l'absence de ces
personnalités je pense notamment à
fadila khattabi dont le travail a été
plutôt généralement salués je regrette
profondément cette situation parce
qu'effectivement fadila a été une très
très bonne vice-présidente et c'est pour
cela qu'ils lui avaient été proposées
sur la liste une place tout à fait
honorable mais non les liens extrêmement
si une plage
mais donc comment vivez-vous cette cette
dissidence à la seul regret et c'est
tout ou c'est déjà beaucoup mais que
voulez-vous que nous ravit face c'est la
main tendue n'est plus possible
non nous avons discuté longuement et je
regrette vraiment qu'une place encore
une fois éligibles lui était proposé et
qu'elle ne l'est pas accepté cécile
prudent on va passer avoue alors europe
ecologie les verts auraient pu s'allier
au parti socialiste on l'a dit vous avez
géré les régions à la fois en bourgogne
et en franche comté avec les exécutifs
sortants vous êtes donc aussi comptable
du bilan des deux régions pourquoi avoir
fait ce choix
premièrement parce qu'on est très
attaché au mode de scrutin proportionnel
qui est autorisé dans le cas des
élections régionales
donc si on saisit pas ses occasions
alors qu on le revendique à longueur de
temps on est complètement incohérent
donc pour nous c'était essentiel de
partir en autonome et deuxièmement on
voulait vraiment rassembler les
écologistes les écologistes de bourgogne
franche comté c'est pour ça qu'on a
réussi à faire un accord facilement et
le mei mouvement écologiste indépendant
d'antoine waechter d'antoine waechter
oui pardon et on a réussi à réunir 30 %
de personnes qui sont non affiliés à un
parti politique mais qui se revendique
écologistes dans leur quotidien et dans
leur mode de vie alors vous dit-on à
rassembler les écologistes mais des
écologistes il y en a sur les listes de
marie-guite dufay avec notamment les
amis de cap 21
il y en a aussi avec la liste qui a
annoncé récemment sa candidature de à
huy l'alliance écologiste indépendante
veillant les écologistes sont pas du
tout a semblé jeter sur vous allez me
demander ça mais si on est rassemblée
parce que on et les écologistes
rassemblés au sens où on est ce qu'ils
proposeront des choses sur le terrain
qui avance on a un programme commun les
écologistes de cap21 ils ont pas
exactement même programme que nous les
écologistes pendant exclamations pour
moi c
oui voilà c'est pas des écologistes et
la rivière devant qua non de points
d'exclamation là ce sont les jours qui
viennent devant quand même un souci
d'écologie lewiner ne partie pour des
raisons individuelles pas pour des
raisons collective menée 6 et les avis
de corinne lepage voilà son nom mais est
ce que c'est un suicidaire quand même
cette stratégie autonomiste entre
guillemets mais ça comporte des risques
après le jeu en vaut la chandelle parce
que plus on sera écouté entendu et c'est
plus on a la possibilité de faire passer
nos idées dans l'opinion publique et
plus on aura de voir plus haut on
pourrait être présentée partout
allez on continue le tour de table
nathalie vermorel la question est un peu
similaire pour les communistes vous vous
êtes parti avec le parti socialiste en
bourgogne dès le premier tour en 2010
pourquoi vous aussi vous êtes comptable
du bilan du conseil régional sortant en
bourgogne
pourquoi ne pas repartir avec les
socialistes aujourd'hui en 2015 mais je
pense que la désunion elle prend corps
dans tout le socle des renoncements des
trahisons car opérait le gouvernement
valls hollande et qui fait
qu'aujourd'hui sur notre ligne politique
nous n'avons une difficulté majeure à
trouver un accord mais la région n'est
pas dans un bocal la région fait partie
de l'ensemble de la nation et dans son
fonctionnement est aujourd'hui la ligne
politique qui est la nôtre qui est de
contester est de combattre les
politiques d'austérité est difficilement
compatible avec la ligne du parti
socialiste qui consiste à la justifier
nous pensons que cette austérité voulu
et cette rupture dans les dotations
cette baisse des dotations
elle s'est véritablement une rupture
profonde y compris la loi neutre sur la
question de la réforme territoriale
donc cela pose une difficulté majeure de
partir au oprah au premier tour avec le
parti socialiste est notre ligne
politique telle que nous l'avons annoncé
comporte également la volonté dans cette
campagne de promouvoir l'égalité des
territoires et la solidarité entre les
personnes de porter des projets en
rupture avec le modèle économique actuel
est d'allier avec audace en grand sur
les questions de démocratie
voilà pourquoi nous avons proposé et
nous nous sommes dit disponible pour un
rassemblement de la gauche autour de ces
axes l'est et nous travaillons avec
d'autres partenaires
au deuxième tour il y aura des alliances
au deuxième tour notre objectif est très
clair très net et nous le disons et là
je parle au nom du parti communiste nous
voulons ne voulons pas que la droite
prenne la main dans cette région donc
nous serons responsables et nous
poserons les actes nécessaires à ce que
la droite ne prennent pas la main dans
cette région mais ça veut dire que si
vous faites plus de 5% et que vous êtes
en capacité de fusionner vous souhaitez
fusionné avec le parti socialiste
donc vous avez dit il ya quelques
minutes que le gouvernement prenait des
décisions qui ne vous je les ai pas
aujourd'hui la question pour moi celle
du deuxième tour c'est celle d'obtenir à
l'issue de la séquence du vote des
politiques à gauche et bien la gauche
est bien ancré à gauche
c'est ça mon objectif donc je pose
suivra cet objectif
jusqu'au bout et il est évident que si
la droite est élu c'est ces politiques
là ne seront pas en place nos que
l'objectif est de faire un score qui
sera largement largement au delà ten
pour ce tout petit beurre dire questions
sur cet aspect politique est ce que vous
ne craignez pas quand est-ce qu'il y
aura visiblement dix listes si elles
vont tout au bout finalement avec
plusieurs partis à gauche est ce que
vous ne craignez pas au niveau régional
à 21 avril 2002 et la gauche sont
éliminés nan nan nan regarder très
clairement le taux d'abstention notre
notre démarche est très clairement en
direction des abstentionnistes des gens
qui ont le coeur à gauche qui qui sont
absolument dépité de l'orientation
qu'elle a pris aujourd'hui et qui
peuvent trouver dans notre liste très
clairement des orientations qui
conforteront leur désir d'une vraie
gauche combative qui va aller combattre
l'austérité qui ne va pas accepter les
solutions telles qu'on ne les propose
aujourd'hui donc je pense que non il ya
largement je rejoins pas votre avis sur
cette question
allez on va du côté droit du plateau à
présent avec françois sauvadet
françois sauvadet votre site de campagne
s'appelle rassemblement bfc comme
bourgogne franche comté mais je
m'interroge sur le mot rassemblement
puisque à côté de vous vous avez un
représentant du modem vous avez dit il
ya quelques mois je veux que le modem
participe au large rassemblement
derrière moi et puis finalement vous
avez changé d'avis pourquoi
changer d'avis d'abord j'ai pas dit je
veux je peux pas décider à la place du
modem je dis je souhaite un large
rassemblement et je veux pas parler moi
qu'aux simples militants comme le fait
comme l'a dit madame du fait qu'ils
s'expriment davantage avec les sociétés
ça parce que je veux c'est m'adresser
aux 2,8 millions de personnes de
bourgogne franche comté qui va avoir
pour un bot un temps le temps du vote le
choix des équipes qui vont gérer pendant
six ans une grande région avec des
compétences nouvelles des compétences
qui vont compter concerne on en
reparlera probablement le développement
économique l'emploi
donc la question de la cohérence de
l'action qu'on va conduire une question
centrale
évidemment donc rassemblés des heures
ces termes c'est est incohérent d'ouvrir
l'alliance droite et centre droit ou
homo d'assembler des hommes et des
femmes qui ont envie de travailler
ensemble et de porter un projet en
assurant nos compatriotes qu'ils seront
en mesure de le porter et qui ne sont
pas sans cesse comme ont assisté pendant
les dernières années dans un débat
interne au parti socialiste
puis quand ils ont réglé le problème
interne dans un débat et des écologistes
et puis on voit bien que c'était le
règne de l'impuissance
donc moi ce que je souhaite c'est que le
débat soit clair alors la relation avec
le modem moi je le souhaitais et
alliances avec le modem et l'âge
rassemblement d'ailleurs vous verrez que
sur les dix que je vais présenter du 6 8
10 jours n'y a pas de précipitation y
aura des hommes et des femmes issus
d'horizons très différents des
professionnels des forces vives puis
aussi des hommes et des femmes qui ont
envie de s'impliquer dans l'associé qui
sont pas tous encartés la relation avec
le modem c'est un problème qui est franc
comtois et bourguignons d'abord j'ai
fait une proposition à françois bayrou
bon j'ai même envoyé un texto je vous le
donnerai à la fin de l'émission c'est
une proposition
il m'a pas répondu bon je comprend
l'embarras du modem aujourd'hui pourquoi
mais c'est un beau pas toujours cohérent
qu'on avoir audité je comprends dans
parade en voiture et la question est
posée au modem c'est que le modem
aujourd'hui dans son expression
nationale françois bayrou dit je veux le
changement
je ne veux plus de cette gauche qui est
au pouvoir je veux le changement et il
se trouve que ces troupes du modem sont
alliés en particulier en bourgogne tous
est en tout cas leur leader avec des
municipalités de gauche donc sa part les
20 ans du club intelligent
mais sur le modem je mens je prends je
prends l'exemple en parler ne dit pas
des contre vérités sur le centre non
content de dire des bêtises vous
pourriez sur nous c'est quand même
quelque chose
j'observe le président du modem de
côte-d'or c'est l'allié de france sur
une seule minute est son adjoint
d'ailleurs ce matin même dans la presse
enfin je vous enverrai la copie parce
que après tout moi moi je suis né vous
êtes julien castagnet dit que vous
pourriez fait pas une politique
j'ai vu ce matin que françois rebsamen
avait donné un accord politique pour la
présentation d'une liste du modem le
modem de l'yonne
le président du modem il est l'adjoint
de monsieur le maire nette hausse à
laisser le modem parler du modem
longtemps à paris je disais les allées
nous concerne c'est pas les problèmes
que vous découvrez cet été vous jouez
peur considériez que le modem et un
routeur même un partenaire potentiel
oui et que vous avez je pense que je
vais vous découvrez maintenant qu'il y
en a même qui y travaillent vous pouvez
faire le commentaire moi je vous dis la
réalité des choses
je souhaite avoir des listes cohérente
je peux pas sur ma liste sur les ce que
je conduirai des hommes ou des femmes
qui sont engagés aux côtés des
socialistes pourquoi parce que je vous
le dis aussi nettement que je le pense
la droite le centre droit et la gauche
c'est pas pareil alors et je veux éviter
la confusion que certains veulent
nourrir
voilà ça c'est simple comme comportement
du titre on va parler après du modem et
un restons sur la constitution de votre
liste vous dites vous la présenter dans
un moment que je vous fasse avant le
mois de novembre
j'entends parler de chape de plomb de la
part de vos propres rangs dans vos
pronos le d'éluder y du tout du jura qui
critiqué la façon dont était constitué
ses listes alors est ce que c'est si
difficile et ce vingt ans de ces normes
dans le scrutin de liste j'ai
aujourd'hui je crois que c'était le cas
pour tout le monde
enfin en tout cas pour nous peut-être
que il ya une envie de travailler avec
tous j'ai aujourd'hui 300 candidats il
ya vous l'avez rappelé espèces sans
cesse place est parmi les 116 places en
toute probabilité selon le score que
feront les uns et les autres avec les
prix vous aurez à les 50 55 58 lui
évidemment tous ceux qui ne sont pas
retenus aux places où ils le souhaitent
vont s'exprimer
en jeu c'est pas celui là l'enjeu c'est
que qu'est ce qu'on va faire pendant les
six ans c'est ça dont je parlais alors
moi je souhaite des équipes je le répète
cohérente passe quand j'entends ce qui
vient d'être dit aujourd'hui on va se
retrouver pour lutter contre la droite
lutter contre la droite ça fait pas un
projet pour la bourgogne franche comté
ça fait une manipulation une coalition
politique
mais derrière ce qui importe c'est de se
dire comme on va travailler
moi je souhaite bon courage madame du
fait non franchement mais j'en ai
beaucoup ya dans son entourage parce que
entre les deux tours il ya dans les
bétons 36 heures utile pour rassembler
tous ceux qui sont divisés au premier
tour à gauche rassembler la gauche des
jalles pl en nombre de collectifs ça
s'appelle où l'on assemblé rassembler
les écologistes divisé s'arrête à
troisième boulot enfin deuxième puis
troisième inscription divisé et puis
rassembler les cobistes derrière c'est
un sacré boulot donc les coalitions
moi ce que je veux c'est qu'on soit
clair vis-à-vis de nos compatriotes dès
le premier tour il faut dire qu'elle
programme on va défendre
qu'est ce qu'on veut pour les 6 ans
parce que c'est ça qui importe donc je
vous dis je veux bâtir une liste de
cohérence voilà christophe grudler on va
passer à vous on a beaucoup parlé du
modèle déjà donc vous en parlez vous ai
remarqué vous avez longtemps espéré
faire l'union avec françois sauvadet
finalement ça ne s'est pas fait du coup
vous dites je serai candidat ce sera
seulement une liste de revanchards menée
par la rancune et la rancoeur non
surtout pas ceux qui me connaissent
savent que c'est que c'est pas mon style
et quand je m'engage dans des campagnes
c'est parce que je m'engage avec le
coeur pour ma région et pour ses
habitants
ce que je veux simplement dire pour
préciser un peu les choses que j'entends
beaucoup de blabla sur le sur le modem
on a une ligne politique au niveau du
goût du mouvement démocrate avec le
soutien de françois bayrou qui est
extrêmement clair nous ne voulons pas de
madame du fait comme présidente de la
bourgogne franche comté et cela françois
sauvadet le sait parfaitement
ceci étant je cherche dans l'alternance
à construire quelque chose qui ne soit
pas l'otage des appareils politiques
parce que quand vous regardez vous
comprenez très clairement que madame
buffet elle ne réunit pas
elle est otage de l'appareil du ps
françois sauvadet qui veut rassembler il
divise il ne fait pas le métier lui dit
les gens ne se reconnaissent pas dans ce
qu'il fait les républicains n'en veulent
pas et il a signé un accord impossible
qui fait qu'aujourd'hui il est entre les
mains de nicolas sarkozy c'est sarkozy
qui composent 75%
sa liste et il viala nous donner des
leçons de moi je suis plus à droite mois
six mois ça mais en fait
son problème c'est qu'il a signé un
accord impossible qu'il a les mains
liées et je vous souhaite je vous
certifie qu'il y aura plus de centristes
sur notre liste de rassemblement pour la
bourgogne franche comté qu'il n'y en
aura sur la sienne mais vous parlez
d'une ligne cohérente
est-ce que c'est cohérent de dire qu'on
veut battre des socialistes est
finalement discuté parce que c'est ce
qui se dit en tout cas avec 3i se
décider si elle était vérifiée et ça
s'est fait notamment à autun la semaine
dernière et vous discutez avec trois
vice présidente socialiste de bourgogne
alors écoutez pour monter s'il vient
c'est extrêmement clair et cohérent de
la millions socialistes n'ont pas
souhaité soyons extrêmement précis j'ai
effectivement rencontré madame otokoré
et ses collègues
la madame khattabi madame ombre et qui
ont un point commun elles ne veulent en
aucun cas de madame du fait comme
président de la région bourgogne franche
comté
françois sauvadet ici présents a même
reçu madame otokoré à paris pour lui
proposer une place sur sa liste dans
l'yonne
alors je crois qu'il faut être tout à
fait cohérent par à toi je me sais que
c'est pas vrai il faut être cohérent par
abc papel jusque là je n'ai pas raison
d'état de l'argent dans les six mois
terminés
non mais si c'est ça ma légion c'est pas
vrai je sais en revanche où ça s'est
déroulé d'ailleurs je n'ai pas vu à
paris début à dijon à bombay mais quand
j'en ai congé après c'est l'endroit où
ça fait mal en langues ont vu et quand
je t'ai vu je leur apprends les états
dans leurs pas voulu et je voulais pas
lui ont proposé les six mois terminés
simplement je vois un point commun avec
madame otokoré qui me paraît important
c'est que elle ne veut en aucun cas de
madame buffet comme présidente de la
région pourrait bien sonner à la enfin
moi non plus elle veut pas non plus des
appareils politiques qui décident à la
place des gens je vous rappelle quand
même qu'il ya 95% des français qui ne
croient plus dans les partis politiques
pas plus au parti sarkozy qu'au parti
hollande
les gens ils veulent croire autre chose
il ya 75 % des français qui ne veulent
pas lors du retour de sarkozy en 2017
il ya 77 % des français qui ne veulent
pas de hollande en 2017 et on devrait
continuer à faire ses gesticulations
politiciennes sur le dos des habitants
de la région bourgogne franche comté
alors moi j'ai partagé un constat avec
madame
deux corées je ne suis pas si ça marche
et on continue à discuter à échanger
positivement autour d'un diagnostic que
nous partageons tous madame du fait
c'est pas la bonne personne pour être
présidente de la région et on veut
sortir des appareils politiques pour
rassembler avec des gens issus de la
vraie vie des gens qui ont des métiers
en bourgogne franche comté
moi je suis chef d'entreprise il ya
d'autres compétences bien investis d'un
terroir local pour porter un peu
dernière dans cette région loin des
appareils de partis politiques qui
polluent le paysage moderne à campêche
dans les théories gens des rues si le
modem dépasser étiquettes et je ne
conduirai par une liste modem on a pris
le contrôle d'un tremblement les stocks
ne soient plus par le modem fait tour à
la parole sous plein ne s'est toujours
pas exprimée sophie montel bonjour alors
vous jouez vous ne semblez pas
particulièrement pressés pour ces
régionales vous avez bien lancer la
campagne c'était la semaine dernière
mais dans la région d'un côté avec
florian philippot vous prenez votre
temps tout à fait vous connaissez la
fable du lièvre et de la tortue cher
monsieur chevreuil moi je m'amuse de des
propos tenus par monsieur sauvadet tout
particulièrement puisque je l'entends
dire qu'il veut une liste cohérente à
droite à monsieur sauvadet je suis
désolé de vous dire que si vous voulez
une liste cohérente à droite il va
falloir virer tous les sortants qui ont
voté à 95 % les projets proposés par
l'exécutif socialiste au conseil
régional de franche comté en la liste du
front national sera sera composé
aux actionnaires votent rarement content
s'abstient beaucoup à on votera aussi
beaucoup contre je peux vous dire que si
l opposition conseil régional face aux
socialistes c'est quand même le front
national est ce ça date pas de cette
mandature là croyez-moi la liste du
front national les listes sont
constitués évidemment vous aurez
quelques surprises d'ailleurs parce que
nous aurons à présenter quelques prises
de guerre quand chez les républicains
notamment et le modem aussi très
prochainement attendez moi je goûte
montplaisir si vous voyez ce que je veux
dire et vous avez évoqué les résultats
des uns et des autres moi je crois très
sincèrement qu'il ya un outsider dans
cette élection régionale en bourgogne
franche comté comme dans quatre autres
régions
c'est le front national compte tenu des
verbes des résultats obtenus de la
dynamique portée par le parti de marine
le pen par le front national
je crois que le front national peut
créer la surprise pas seulement au
premier tour au deuxième alors moi ce
que j'aimerais savoir dès ce soir
fade et dès maintenant ce que j'aimerais
savoir c'est si puisque vous êtes
visiblement sur le fond très compatibles
entre l'ump et républicain je sais plus
trop comment il faut vous appeler l
parti socialiste j'aimerais savoir
mois-ci front national arrive très
largement en tête au soir du premier
tour de ces élections régionales
si madame du fait monsieur son bad
sauvadet ont prévu de faire liste
commune parce que ça a déjà été annoncé
dans d'autres régions que pour faire
barrage au front national
s'ils ne font ils restent sur le poser
leur position évidemment le front
national aura toutes ses chances de
gagner s'ils répondront s'ils veulent
mais en tout cas on reste un petit peu
sur votre sur votre liste
donc vous dites qu'elle va être
constituée c'est vous qui la donne
allait constituer bien évidemment oui
bah on attend en tout cas qu'elle soit
publiée
edouard ferrand lui a déjà fait savoir
qu'il ne se représentait pas parce qu'il
était député européen et qu'il pensait
que cette fonction nécessité d'être à
plein temps au parlement de strasbourg
vous êtes aussi députée européenne alors
est ce qui vaut pour lui ne vaut pas
pour vous goûtez le choix des douars et
le choix des douars moi j'ai été j'ai
été choisi par la commission nationale
d'investiture et par le bureau politique
du front national pour mener cette liste
en bourgogne franche comté edwards a des
responsabilités un peu plus importante
que moi au parlement européen puisqu'il
est vice-président nous avons réussi à
constituer un groupe rock des nations et
des libertés
et il a effectivement il est beaucoup
plus commenté la délégation voilà les
chefs de la délégation française donc il
est
il est en terme de temps beaucoup c'est
plus chronophage pour lui que pour moi
on passe à vos projets on va parler un
peu du fond parce qu'il faut quand même
et donc de vos projets avec notamment ce
qu'ils voulaient rapidement quand on
aborde le fond c'est juste sur le front
national on voit bien que l'opinion
beaucoup de gens sont son vivent des
situations extrêmement difficiles
haïssions dans dans le désarroi réel
qu'il faut entendre cette inquiétude et
cette colère des gens mais dans le même
temps il faut qu'on sache que le front
national n'apporte aucune solution à
part celui de m marine le pen sur des on
alone on a du mérite je suis là et
j'attends de voir les propositions du
front national devance allait devenir
franchement j'allais venir en service et
s'entraîner je sais pas on parle de
fermer les frontières alors est ce que
madame monte elle va fermer la frontière
suisse
j'aimerais le savoir l'union sûr c'est
pas vraiment une compétence du concert
et je suis désolé ah bah je suis de
fermer parce que les relations
importance extrême tension
le front national n'est pas l'alpha et
l'oméga de la vie politique française
le député européen républicain pas plus
tard qu'hier applaudir à tout rompre le
discours de françois hollande
vous avez raison monsieur se mélangent
précise que cette émission est
enregistrée jeudi et diffusé samedi donc
quand madame ont-elles parti hier
c'était mercredi en fait voilà donc je
reviens à la politique économique
madame du fait je me retourne vers vous
une mesure pour favoriser le
développement économique dans notre
région ce sera la principale compétence
des futurs grands conseils régionaux que
faire pour développer l'économie en
bourgogne franche comté
si aujourd'hui on avait une baguette
magique ça se saurait pour lutter contre
le chômage qui est la préoccupation
numéro un donc lutter contre le chômage
et favoriser la création d'emplois ça
relève de tout un arsenal de mesures
c'est pas une mesure
je voudrais dire dans le peu de temps
qui est un parti là qu'il y a trois
choses et
essentiel pour moi c'est que
premièrement dans une économie qui
aujourd'hui est en pleine mutation et
qui détruit des emplois
il faut absolument que la première
compétence que nous avons niveau de la
région qui est la formation servent à
protéger au maximum les emplois c'est
dans cette région que nous avons inventé
le concept former plutôt que chômer pour
que dans les entreprises en difficulté
dans les entreprises qui subissent les
mutations d'aujourd'hui les hommes et
les femmes qui travaillent soient
protégés deuxièmement les emplois on en
perd mais on en crée aussi et si on ne
crée pas tous les emplois que l'on créé
la situation serait encore pire
et donc pour cela nous avons à investir
aux côtés des chefs d'entreprise à les
aider à prendre des risques quand ils
sont sur des démarrages notamment
d'entreprises qui demandent des capitaux
notamment les entreprises qui sont issus
de la recherche donc l'investissement
les aider en matière de formation quand
je vois aujourd'hui comment nous avons
aidé une entreprise comme celle ci ait
sa mort tôt qui travaillent sur le luxe
sur la qualité à former ses salariés à
l'égard des et bien ça a été un résultat
très important de la part de la région
qui investit en formation il faut aider
sur ce qui est équipements et il faut
miser sur l'économie verte
de façon plus générale jeudi sur
l'économie de la qualité et l'économie
de la qualité c'est pas simplement celle
qui produit de la qualité comme on pensa
à la microtechnique à l'horlogerie aux
produits de luxe mais c'est celle aussi
qui ne détruit pas d'emplois
c'est celle qui ne s'assoit pas sur une
économie financière et cette économie de
la qualité il faut absolument la poussée
donc premièrement former plutôt que
chômer ceux qui subissent deuxièmement
un panorama de deux mesures pour être
aux côtés de ceux qui investissent et
troisièmement troisièmement n'arrête la
travailler vraiment sur la
représentation que les uns et les autres
franc comtois bourguignon jeunes moins
jeunes ont de l'entreprise on ne croit
plus que dans l'entreprise il y a un
avenir
on ne croit
que les métiers industriels et les
métiers artisanaux ont un avenir parce
que on connaît mal
ces métiers et il faut absolument
engager une mobilisation de tous pour
faire connaître ses métiers
en ouvrant les entreprises en organisant
des portes souffert en organisant des
débats qui s'adresse aux jeunes
alors on imagine que on peut adhérer à
peu près tout ça c'est à ces propos la
région c'est vrai soral la plus
industrielle de france avec dit cette
source en france comptait déjà la
première région et et n'oublions labour
beau je parle de la programmation dont
c'était la première qu'est ce qui fait
la différence pour vous dans votre
programme se sont d'abord on veut pas
s'exonérer de son propre bilan quand on
était en charge des responsabilités dans
une région et je le dis à madame du fait
les chiffres si les recettes peuvent pas
être comme sa séduisante et gilson la
cruelle 135 mille chômeurs dans notre
grande région bourgogne franche comté
cinquante mille de plus 50 mille de plus
et puis des chiffres sur lequel qui sont
qui sont à mes yeux inacceptable
les crédits à l'apprentissage qui ont
baissé de 12% dans notre région le
nombre d'apprentis kbc baisser non pas
les crues le nombre des apprentis et
d'apprentissage n'ont pas baissé c'est
pour cela que je répète les crédits ont
baissé de 12 % des utilisations non les
désinvestissements mais c'est faux jean
de luz y mettons les cfa serait en très
grande difficulté dont vous ne pouvez
pas dire cela que je pouvais je remercie
parce que j'ai l'impression je pourrais
pas m'exprimer
non donc un constat cruel une situation
est très difficile cinquante mille
chômeurs de plus pendant la période où
madame du fait au staff de
responsabilité est beaucoup moins
d'apprentis alors j'ai fait ça donc de
proposition d'abord effectivement la
formation c'est la clé on peut pas se
satisfaire de voir 25% de nos jeunes
s'inscrire au chômage 25 % dans notre
grande région bourgogne franche comté
l'apprentissage moi j'ai fait une
proposition de bas c'est que on va
travailler davantage avec ceux qui font
l'emploi avec ceux qui prendront des
apprentis avec ceux qui veulent faire du
tutorat et j'ai fait une proposition
cette crypte conférence régionale des
métiers et de l'artisanat pour qu'avec
les professionnels on se met en
projection sur les métiers d'aujourd'hui
c'est sur les métiers de demain
regardez les voitures le réparation des
voitures a complètement évolué
aujourd'hui vous avez de l'informatique
embarquée il faut que ces fassois vie à
niveau pour pouvoir permettre la
formation de nos jeunes qui auront à
reprendre aujourd'hui c'est pas le cas
on sait pas le cas quand on prépare
quelque chose que je souhaitais la
deuxième chose que je souhaitais c'est
pas une inflation annuelle que je
souhaite moi pour la grande région
c'est d'avoir une gestion prévisionnelle
des formations et de l'employabilité de
l'emploi regardez ce qui se passe nous
avons nous à l'orage et d'employabilité
c'est rendre quelqu'un qui est au bord
du chemin en situation de pouvoir
parvenir vers la situation de l'emploi
et l'emploi c'est quand on a permis à
cette personne qui est au bord du chemin
de retrouver les conditions de
l'employabilité de trouver un emploi et
je sais de quoi je parle je préside un
conseil départemental et donc je
pourrais d'ailleurs si vous inviter à
venir voir comment ça se passe
concrètement donc nous avons nous devons
mettre une gestion prévisionnelle des
emplois des formations les mettre en
perspective
ça veut dire aussi qu'il faut soutenir
l'activité économique et l'emploi
moi je souhaite que dans l'industrie
j'ai fait deux propositions c'est qu'on
s'inscrive plus vigoureusement comme
l'ont fait une ou deux régions en france
dans l'industrie du futur dans l'appel à
projets pour se mettre en situation pour
nos entreprises et nos pme donc
troisième proposition c'est un des
volets sur les clauses 3 et 2
l'industrie du futur matin je veux pas
polémiquer mais mme dufay ce matin c'est
pas le sujet soit le sujet n'y a pas eu
d'appel à projets y a pas eu d'appel à
projets dans l'industrie du futur je
suis désolé désolé pas usine fait le
monde même chose
troisième chose je souhaite qu'on sorte
aussi pour l'agroalimentaire là aussi le
pôle nucléaire bourguignon vitagora le
pôle évidemment véhicules du futur
la vallée d'énergie tout ça il faut
qu'on se met en perspective et qu'on
soit beaucoup plus vigoureux sur
l'investissement l'innovation
dernier sujet moi je souhaite qu'on
sorte d'une écologie punitive
quand je vois que toutes les
propositions faites dessous
tiens à l'agroalimentaire à
l'agriculture ont été vus non pas comme
une production durable
mais comme avec d une sorte d' écologie
punitive fait qu'on en sorte
et puis qu'on sort d'une économie
administrée moi je vous invite un jour
aller voir que les dix spots et des
dispositifs qui a dans des régions
actuelle dirigée par les socialistes
c'est devenu incompréhensible comprend 6
pour la france vous fait plonger dans la
bourgogne franche comté
vous faites une plongée il n'y a
absolument aucune perspective claire
d'avenir de tracé par la région à des
dispositifs relais c'est aller au ciné
au téléthon non mais je termine là
dessus et puis la troisième chose je
pense qu'il faudra qu'on s'inscrive dans
une gestion beaucoup plus active des
financements européens pour lequel il
faut pas les laisser repartir comme
c'est le cas aujourd'hui quatre là
dessus le programme est donc je peux pas
vous laisser dire ça monsieur sauvadet
cela soit 20 10% des fonds européens
sont engagés
françois sauvadet disais tout à l'heure
que le front national n'avait pas de
programme quelles sont vos propositions
en matière de développement et mais je
vais vous répondre mais je trouve assez
goûteux d'écouter les propos tenus par
la candidate socialiste et le candidat a
eu 10 les républicains ils sont quand
même il ya quand même à l'aspect
schizophrénique dans cette affaire parce
que on a l'impression qu'ils n'ont
jamais gouverné or nous sommes sous un
gouvernement socialiste et il ya encore
quelques années nous étions sous un
gouvernement de dix de droite ou quand
même monsieur sarkozy a réussi l'exploit
d'ajouter un million de chômeurs par les
conseils que je donne alors les comptes
le conseil régional effectivement le
conseil régional n'a pas de levier très
puissant vous remédier à la catastrophe
à la catastrophe de la
désindustrialisation et de taux de
chômage qui est et des défaillances
d'entreprises ceci dit nous avons quand
même des leviers notamment les marchés
publics
alors pour ça il aurait évidemment si on
avait voulu être un levier total il
aurait évidemment pas fallu que la
gauche et la droite vaude le nouveau
code des marchés publics telle que
voulue par l'union européenne mais en
attendant il ya des clauses
environnementales et des call clauses
sociales qui peuvent être actionnés pour
faire qu'on privilégie l'emploi local
plutôt d'accueil d'aller chercher des
travailleurs détachés comme ça se voit
sur tous les grands chantiers mais pas
que sur les grands chantiers comme la
lgv comme l'hôpital médian où on
s'aperçoit que ce sont les travailleurs
détachés qui viennent à 80% les
entreprises sous traitent avec des
enfants
entreprise étrangère et qui viennent
réaliser les travaux il ya aussi des
exemple tout bête madame dufay a fait
réaliser des travaux dans la cour du
conseil régional de franche comté c'est
une entreprise du haut doubs qui obtenu
une partie des marchés et on s'est
aperçu que cette entreprise avec avait
sous-traité avec une entreprise venant
du portugal ce sont donc des maçons
portugais qui ont réalisé les travaux
dans la cour du conseil régional ce que
mais comment on fait pour contrôler
l'entrée bien sûr on veut savoir un
monde abordent je le regrette je votre
europe je la regrette tous les jours
quand je vois les dégâts qu'elles créent
sur pour mon pays et pour pour mon
peuple
ce qu'on fait c'est qu'on met des
clauses sociales et des clauses
environnementales pourquoi aller
chercher des entreprises à 5500 2500
3000 km y'a pas une ya pas d loi qui
interdit aux équipes qui permettent de
réduire la pollution et qui permettrait
d'avoir des clauses aurait
environnementale pour justement faire
comprend plus court comprend les
entreprises qu'on a sous la main
et puis et puis vous avez raison il ya
aussi des d'autres points qui peuvent
être normalement on peut manger français
dans les cantines des lycées faire
travailler nos agriculteurs ça aussi
c'est une idée et puis on la voit de
plus en plus dans les départements de 19
ans oui c'est vrai c'est très bien ça
arrive juste s'est il met six ans à
chaque échéance électorale il nous leur
servent et ça se met 2 me de ça se fait
ça se présente avant les élections et ça
s'applique pas forcément derrière voilà
madame du fait effectivement elle a un
bilan
moi je vois là je connais le bilan de
madame du fait parce que je la pratique
depuis un certain nombre d'années
je note que le nombre de défaillances
d'entreprises a explosé je note que le
chômage augmente
je note que madame du fai vous parlez de
la carte des formations mais enfin votre
carte des formations elle est tellement
bien fait que on a vraiment l'impression
je voulais déjà dit à plusieurs reprises
en séance du conseil régional que c'est
conforme pour en fait sortir vous l'avez
dit d'ailleurs formés pour ne pas chômer
donc c'est former les gens pour les
faire sortir des statistiques du chômage
mais il ya j'ai jamais sentie lésée
revanche est d'être des ménages
j'ai jamais ça j'ai jamais on sent prise
c'est le défendrai cette volonté
d'aboutir à des formations qui dérivent
sur un emploi que chacun s'exprime
monteil laissé entendre que
la région n'a pas de compétence
économique je vous rappelle je vous
rappelle quand même et il a tous les
leviers qu'il faut car les départements
sont dessaisis de la compétence
économique au 1er janvier et maintenant
la première collectivité locale en ligne
pour défendre l'emploi
c'est la région c'est le conseil que
faire ou que faire on vient sur la base
d'écoutés c'est très simple quand j'ai
entendu beaucoup de bilan beaucoup de
poncifs
mais en fait on cache la vérité aux gens
la vérité pour les gens c'est quoi pour
les trois millions de dhs habitants de
l'abdomen franche comté c'est un taux de
chômage à 9 6%
et c'est le fait qu'on est en crise et
contre on s'en sortira pas tant fera pas
une croissance mondiale à 3% et que tant
qu aura pas ça on ne créera pas de
l'emploi dont il localement à nous de
trouver des solutions innovantes dans le
domaine de l'industrie notamment
extrêmement important ici pour qu'on
puisse réussir chez 4e re et voulons
d'une autre blake qui a relié la lame du
seuil est le lead and roses et riespach
c'est un peu ternes à toute une page
aujourd'hui dans le journal c'est la
fête aujourd'hui jeudi je peux c'est la
fête dans cette entreprise qui a failli
effectivement fermé
si la région n'avait pas été à ses côtés
pour investir dans la reprise de cette
entreprise elle ne remettrait pas
aujourd'hui voilà près de couper la
parole aux autres ne sais pas ce que
vous savez faire
c'est ça justement qui est inquiétant
pour le pot pour l'avenir moi j'aime ex
il vous serez vous dis ces idées reçues
c'est la parole samedi que les arguments
ne vous conviennent pas c'est pas une
façon honnête magie sur le fond le dis
donc sur lausanne et solutions mais j'ai
dit oui ciolino innovant par exemple
structurer les filières
aujourd'hui on entend dire madame buffet
en franche comté ont fait si on fait ça
demain c'est pas la franche comté c'est
la bourgogne franche comté oublier un
petit peu que vous êtes là représentant
que de la franche comté il ya un regard
à war c'est aussi laissez moi j'entends
déjà longtemps préposé aux propositions
si je suis coupé non loin de se
structurer les filières oui et la vallée
de l'énergie a à belfort mais à chalon
sur saône qui travaillent sur l'énergie
depuis très longtemps a bien su ça doit
être demain une filière unique
willy et le véhicule du futur à
montbéliard mais il ya également un pôle
automobile à magny-cours côté de nevers
ça doit travailler ensemble c'est ce que
j'appelle structure est solide
les filles et ensuite au lieu de
saupoudrer comme vous le faites
dz de quelques milliers d'euros à plein
de petites entreprises moi je souhaite
demain je serai demain soutenir
exclusivement les entreprises qui ont
une rupture technologique innovante pour
la quatrième révolution industrielle qui
doit demain nous permettre d'avoir de
l'emploi c'est la recherche et
développement
c'est l'internet c'est là que les
collections c'est la mise en réseau tout
ça c'est quelque chose d'extrêmement
dynamique venait pas de vision là dessus
d'ailleurs les élèves sont heureux que
vous faites dans le domaine économique
sont est extrêmement faible il est en
passe manière chose je propose
l'autonomie énergétique dont nos
villages on peut créer des usines à
méthane on peut il ya 17 % de nos
concitoyens en bourgogne franche comté
qui sont victimes de la précarité
énergétique
on a la capacité grâce à des aides de
l'europe grâce à des aides de l'état de
mettre en place une autonomie
énergétique dont chacun de nos
territoires
il faut réagir là qui draine une bonne
transition pour donner la parole à
cécile présenter madame du fait maritime
on est complètement là dedans rien on
les annonce et yann ont alors cessé
après deux séries positif on ne m'a pas
du tout les territoires travail pour
être autonome dans la production de
l'énergie
mark hamill fait on va donner la parole
à votre voisine s'il vous plaît cécile
prud'hommes afin de vous si vous
europe ecologie les verts vous souhaitez
une certaine rupture avec l'économie
d'aujourd'hui donc fini les aides par
exemple du conseil régional à des
projets comme center parcs
on le voit dans le doubs en saône et
loire c'est ça pour vous qui est
important ça fait partie des choses sur
lesquelles
oui c'est important mais la première
main parce que c'est un des projets or
seuls qui correspond à rien qui ne
correspond surtout pas à l'ats qu'il
pourrait créer des emplois ne vous
forcez les emplois précaires des emplois
intérimaires des emplois mal payés enfin
c'est pas pas de l'emploi comme nous on
souhaite toi est ce qu'on souhaite
justement pour les zones rurales
c'est revitaliser l'emploi vient
l'agriculture biologique et locale parce
que c'est une façon d'être légion très
agricole voilà exactement et ce à une
fois que ce sera développée c'est à la
fois bon pour la santé des lycéens si on
arrive à passer à 80% d'alimentation bio
et local mais biologique dans les lycées
c'est bon pour les lycéens c'est bon
pour les consommateurs c'est bon pour
les agriculteurs qui sont les premières
victimes de l'agriculture non biologique
c'est bon aussi pour l'emploi pour les
zones rurales parce que nous on est
vraiment attaché à la redynamisation des
espaces ruraux et c'est la pause à offre
la possibilité de remettre de l'emploi
dans les territoires ruraux parce que ça
l'agriculture biologique c'est une
agriculture qui demande plus de mal de
main d'oeuvre que l'agriculture
productiviste et du coup savard permet
de lancer un cercle vertueux parce que
s'il ya des gens des campagnes qui
travaillent s'il ya des salles enclenche
un retour au commerce a enclenché un
retour à la restauration
bref ça enclenche un retour à la vraie
vie dans les villages et ça nous c'est
une mesure à laquelle on tient beaucoup
alors ça c'est l'agriculture mais pour
tout le reste de l'économie
et bien pour tout le reste de l'économie
on a tous les métiers liés à l'artisanat
qui sont encore une fois qu'ils
répondent aussi à la précarité
énergétique parce que ça permet de
l'isolation des bâtiments
parce que nous tous les emplois qu'on
pense et qu'on veut créer c'est qu'ils
soient compatibles avec l'impératif
climatique
donc il ya tout l'isolation du vêtement
tout le développement des énergies
renouvelables
tout ce qui lie à l'innovation sociale
notamment sur l'innovation sociale de
et de l'après pétrole parce que tout ça
c'est des métiers c'est la recherche
enfin bref tous ces métiers n'a nathalie
vermorel oui merci
quelles priorités alors pour nous la
mère des batailles c'est celle du
développement de la de l'industrie
l'action industriel je pense elle doit
être vraiment durable dans une politique
de filière effectivement la cie filière
énergétique la filière des transports il
faut le concevoir dans une synergie dans
une réponse globale aux besoins de la
branche de quillan qui englobe
effectivement la question de la
formation professionnelle qui a déjà été
évoqué que je ne rêvais pas re développe
pas effectivement la question des moyens
des conseils régionaux les conseils
régionaux ce au fond quand on les
regarde bien c'est quand même peu de
moyens c'est 1,2 pour cent du pib de la
bourgogne franche comté
donc ce que nous devons travailler c'est
des effets elle les effets de levier est
ce que j'ai entendu dire c'est qu'il
faut concentrer les ressources dans
certains endroits
oui mais on connaît bien cette politique
qui consiste à rose est toujours au même
endroit certes on a une belle fleur mais
à côté c'est la désertification la plus
totale et ça n'est pas notre façon
d'envisager les choses
le revêtement concrètement concrètement
la question qui se pose pour l'aide pour
le développement des entreprises c'est
l'accès au crédit aujourd'hui et l'accès
au crédit pour nous c'est la question de
comment on va actionner le levier de la
banque puisque je joue comme je vous le
disais des montants tconcert défend
économique des conseils régionaux ne
peuvent pas répondre aux demandes de
crédits ne sont pas suffisants donc la
création de fonds régionaux qui seraient
abondés par les parlers par les fonds
publics
les nôtres celles des banques publiques
mais aussi les banques est extrêmement
important avec un mode de gouvernance on
permettrait quand même aux acteurs qui
ont bénéfice de 7,2 de ses fonds
d'intervenir c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui
les salariés les petits entrepreneurs
n'ont pas accès dans la gouvernance à
ces fonds donc ça nous paraître une une
gestion beaucoup plus démocratique des
critères d'attribution qui pourraient
non pas lié haute
à la question de la rentabilité mais la
question si de lutte
lité sociale et pour attribuer parce que
je balaye vite malheureusement le temps
un contre un s'il vous plaît une
condition est à mettre en oeuvre pour
les entreprises qui sollicitent des
fonds publics
c'est de connaître l'ensemble des aides
publiques déjà perçu par les entreprises
parce qu'aujourd'hui il ya une omerta là
dessus on ne peut pas savoir où sont
passés les 177 millions d'euros de nos
régions qui ont été attribués dans le
cadre du cic au et le client beau
compétitivité je pensais un peu
compétitif aussi effectivement nous
aidons d'aider des petites entreprises
les grands groupes se présente aussi à
la région
et je pense que ils reçoivent des fonds
qui pourraient être réattribuées adéens
privilégier les petites entreprises
plutôt que les grands groupes
madame du juste réagir sur les fonds
d'investissements parce que nous en
avons déjà mis en place des fonds
d'investissement avec les banques pour
intervenir à tous les stades de
développement des entreprises
ça ça marche très bien mais bon les
entendre aux les entreprises en sont
très satisfaits
bon sauf encore effectivement beaucoup
d'entreprises hésitent à ouvrir leur
capital
à l'extérieur il faut absolument
convaincre l'entreprise que c'est dans
son intérêt
mais ces fonds d'investissement ils nous
permettent de faire démarrer notamment
aujourd'hui je pense à des exemples dans
la santé des entreprises qui sont en
train d'inventer des thérapies
innovantes qui auront lieu demain de
lutte notamment contre le cancer
elle émane de la recherche elles ont
besoin d'énormes capitaux et c'est par
nos fonds d'investissement qu'on peut
les aider mais c'est vrai que ce qui est
compliqué c'est convaincre l'entreprise
de s'ouvrir à l'extérieur à ce moment là
je veux bien madame buffet nous décrit
un monde parfait où tout va bien
les entreprises sont contentes quand on
est sur le terrain c'est pas du tout la
réalité
d'ailleurs même des fonds
d'investissement de la bpi sont adossées
souvent des prêts bancaires dans le
public un mais sans une région on est
dans une région franche comté bourgogne
c'a vraiment j'éduque a vraiment joué
petit bras sur ces questions de
mobilisation d'une ressource financière
qui est abondante aujourd'hui sur les
marchés
et je partage que vous avez dit madame
et on a une ressource abondante sur les
marchés qui n'est pas mobilisée
on prie pour lancer des grands plans
d'investissement puisque je les dis on a
baissé de 10 % les investissements
bourgogne franche comté 10%
c'est ça la réalité c'est fait vous
ferez votre travail de journaliste vous
irez vérifier à l'avenir les chiffres
que j'annonce sur des chiffres vrai
puisque je les ai faits vérifiés vous et
vérifiable le deal à résister c'est pas
une réalité
voilà un bon match mais simplement moi
je pense que nous avons un vrai défi et
on parlera aussi sur les infrastructures
assure la mobilité un vrai défi sur la
mobilisation de fonds on a notamment
bâti un fond avec nos amis alsaciens un
fonds d'investissements importants en
volume qui n'a pas servi à la bourgogne
franche comté puis seule entreprise
seuls entrepris mari vient d'être ouvert
du fait moi je voudrais qu'on se mette
d'accord sur un point si madame du fait
pour vous la conviction c'est que tout
est bien dans la région bourgogne
franche comté
tout va bien tout est pour le mieux dans
le meilleur des mondes alors madame
discuter avec les militants socialistes
allaient faire le tour comme vous le
faites dans les cafés débats mais
souffrez quand même qu'on puisse faire
d'autres propositions pour l'avenir
d'une région fait quelque chose que vous
avez une gestion faisant adhérer et que
vous avez une gestion petit pourquoi je
fais des propositions très fier et je te
jure je fais des propositions
donc je pense qu'il ya deux sujets sur
la précarité énergétique concernait la
parole comme attendu sur la précarité
énergétique était soulevée par par
christophe grudler il a tout à fait
raison
là encore on n'est pas dans le même
calibre il faut qu'on mobilise les fonds
notamment de la banque européenne
d'investissement qui sont des fonds
disponibles pour avoir avec des emprunts
obligataires
une mise à disposition massif qui
permettent d'avoir un effet levier sur
l'économie et sur l'emploi
ça vaut pour l'innovation et je disais
ça vaut pour l'innovation 200 millions
de crédits on a beau me dire c'est pas
vrai 200 millions de crédits à
l'innovation de repartir vers bruxelles
faute d'avoir été mobilisés une faute
d'avoir été mobilisés écoutez moi bien
quand dans le même temps vous à nous
avons écoutez moi bien dix fois plus de
défaillances d'entreprises en bourgogne
franche comté qui derna dans l'est du
pays
fissot clientèle fait se fera quant à
lui demandé la parole depuis un moment
sur le jeu regrette d'ailleurs que le
débat que le débat sur l'économie et sur
le développement économique soit aussi
court ça mériterait vraiment pas sûr
ferait alors sachez les on va l'annoncer
de suite on en fera sur le développement
économique spécifiquement le 14 novembre
alors concrètement au conseil régional
de franche comté
je parle de celui je connais puisque j
sièges je peux vous assuré monsieur
sauvadet que vos amis des républicains
ont voté toutes les propositions en
matière de développement économique
proposé par les socialistes
moi je dirais à madame à madame du fait
nous avons deux pendant des années le
front national a réclamé que soient
mises en place des avances remboursables
aux entreprises plutôt que les
subventions directes
nous avons été aussi dans cette
assemblée un des rares à des rares
partis à dire qu'il ne fallait pas
subventionner les grands groupes
effectivement si le front national gagne
la région n'y aura plus de subventions
pour les grands groupes archi
bénéficiaires ça fait un peu peur avec
les ralentis connaissait référent nous
vérifierons oui oui bob avec des
créations d'emplois à la clé si vous
considérez qu'on n'a pas à s'en occuper
mais vous allez l'expliqué a suscité des
sucres avaler on l'espère manière dont
elles se sont évadés vous où vous pouvez
voir reprocher aux autres de couper la
parole je crois que vous êtes vous êtes
pas mal dans le genre je parle moi là
donc je disais que le front national a
pendant des années et réclamer que
soient mises en place des avances
remboursables madame du fait à chaque
fois monté dans les tours en nous disant
mais les avances remboursables ça n'est
pas possible ça ne sert à rien ça n'est
pas un levier efficace et ô miracle un
mini bain je peux reprocher aux
déclarations sur les procès-verbaux la
poussette refuser un agréement tueuse
puisque nous les avons il ya trois ans
et ya trois ans quatre ans madame madame
je mâche à désir madame sauvadet madame
du fait madame du fait tout d'un coup a
eu la fourrière les avances
remboursables était fort utile est
beaucoup plus utile d'ailleurs que les
subventions directes aux entreprises
parce que la cour des comptes entre
autres a fait de nombreuses études en
expliquant que les subventions directes
aux entreprises ne crée et ne maintienne
absolument pas l'emploi voilà les
petites entreprises le tissu économique
est tenu et soutenu encore l'activité
soutenue uniquement madame même du fait
vous le savez comme moi par les pme et
les pmi les tpe les artisans et les
commerçants et c'est eux qui ont besoin
du soutien mais évidemment je le redis
malgré
cela dit monsieur grue de l'air tout à
l'heure la région a beau avoir hérité de
la compétence économique les leviers
sont sont fort peu nombreux par rapport
au levier nationale parce que les
leviers c'est pas là qu'il faut aller
les chercher parce que les leviers ses
62 milliards d'euros qui sont
actuellement en dépôt dans nos banques
comment on va les mobiliser et c'est
pour ça que la création d'un fonds ou
demanderait aux banques de m ah ah
on les a sauvés en 2008 les banques
aujourd'hui elles ont un devoir
vis-à-vis de la nation
elles ont un devoir vis-à-vis des
chômeurs elles ont un devoir vis-à-vis
des élus est sage moi ce nom c'est notre
proposition un fonds public régional
avec des fonds publics fonds régional
mais avec une gestion paritaire une
gestion démocratique et sur des critères
fondamentaux qui sont ceux de l'utilité
sociale des de l'argent voilà pourquoi
est ce que les fonds je pense que
l'analyse est effectivement très bonne
présidente ni régionaux mais vous ferez
une très bonne conseillère régionale des
alliances inattendues sur ce front
pourquoi est ce que je valais sont pas
mobilisés notamment en franche comté
tout simplement parce qu'aujourd'hui on
n'a pas de vision économique
on a que de la gestion courante on a des
les élus ont délégué aux services la
direction de la région franche comté
nous annoncer chien aura encore de
l'industrie titude d'euros donc il n'ya
pas de vision générale explique abel for
clara gaymard vient à belfort patronne
de ge electric france
la seule proposition de la région
bourgogne franche comté j'étais à cette
réunion avec madame buffet c'est dire
j'ai un joli centre de formation
utiliser mon centre de formation alors
que la vision c'est à dire l'énergie on
va la structure et sur toute la région
bourgogne franche comté où on va mais on
va vous développez la vallée l'énergie
on va la faire irradier juste jusqu'en
bourgogne et gère électrique trouvera
quelque chose d'extrêmement york à san
marin cabaret pour a débuté hier et
clara gaymard y est prête tout à fait
tout à fait mais on n'y a pas cette
vision aujourd'hui il n'y a pas séduit
projet donc il n'y a pas de fonds
investis ce qui est pas un regard
innovant il n'y a pas non plus une
confiance je vous rappelle que la région
est là pour fournir le terreau qui
permet aux entreprises de pousser on
n'est pas là pour faire le entrepreneurs
à la place des entrepreneurs mais il
faut qu'ils aient ce terreau et cette
vision sans vision on va faire du
saupoudrage la petite gestion courante
et on va gentiment décliné
celle ci le prix d'or mais ce qu'il faut
aider on va vous redonner la parole à
marc du fait mais c'est si le programme
d'abord est-ce qu'il faut aider des
grosses entreprises comme general
electric et alstom
en quelques minutes donc elles ont
besoin non mais nous on préférait
nettement aider les petites pme locales
innovantes qui créent de l'emploi non
délocalisable qui ont tous eu tous
d'ailleurs on va en parler
enfin on en a parlé jeudi dernier avec
eva joly
non mais c'est essentiel de créer de
l'emploi pour les petites pme est par
exemple tout enfin nous on voudrait que
la formation professionnelle se cale sur
les besoins et pas soit pas dans
l'absolu parce que par exemple en haute
saône on a rencontré des personnes qui
arrivent pas à pourvoir des offres
d'emploi c'est des gens qui pose des
fenêtres et il trouve pas d'artisans
pour aller lors de pour embaucher le
problème il est il ya une inadéquation
entre l'offre et la demande et nous on
veillera c'est la connaissance de ces
métiers il ya une très mauvaise vision
sur ses métiers les arts c'est aussi on
ressort c'est aussi du ressort du
conseil régional notamment la carte des
formations macha prison reste quelques
secondes avant la première
responsabilité avant même le financement
des formations c'est de travailler sur
cette connaissance des métiers et nous
nous y employons excusez moi
depuis des années nous avons on y
arrivera pas et c'est ce qu'il faut
faire parce que vous savez le dialogue
exclusif avec 5 cfa qui vient discuter
avec la présidente ou ses représentants
pour aller discuter le bout de gras
s'est terminée ce temps là une vision
complètement du passé n'est pas dit ce
qu'il faut aujourd'hui c'est avoir une
gestion prévisionnelle je répète d
emploi des cadres pour permettre une
adéquation entre les emplois
d'aujourd'hui et de demain
s'arrêter quelques minutes le débat va
continuer mais rassurez vous on s'arrête
juste quelques minutes le temps du
journal on se retrouve à 12h05 pour la
suite de ce débat ici à besançon